well collectively we should just be
doing a lot more collectively we will
solve these problems much faster as a
wee than as a me so basically anything
we can get people to do together i'm in
favor of because the more we bring
people together the more they going to
find out what they have in common the
more they going to find out what we can
do about these problems so having more
we it's the most important thing we can
do individual I think the key thing is
to understand or try to understand that
when I do something it has consequence
and then the consequence try to
understand that we're part of a long
connection causation now the fact is you
actually can't do it if you got up if
you get up tomorrow morning but what's
the first thing you do when you leave
your house in the morning so when you
brush your teeth a little thought
exercise try while you're brushing your
teeth to think about all of the
consequences that flow from the act of
brushing your teeth where did the metal
in the tube come from where did the
plastic come from how did the toothpaste
get to be white how is it brought to you
what happened to the workers have made
it where the water come from how is it
stored how is it transported where is it
going the electrons that light your face
so you don't just like make a mess of
yourself how did that happen try to
think of all the chains of causation
that you're a part of you will not be
able to do it if we could all twice a
day put ourselves through that exercise
I think we would be less certain than
therefore probably wiser we would
understand that
we should tread more gently